gamma knife también conocido como
radiocirugía estereotáctica es un tipo
de tratamiento por radiación que se
utiliza frecuentemente para tumores
cerebrales también puede utilizarse para
otras afecciones de la cabeza
gamma knife es un procedimiento
quirúrgico no invasivo que no requiere
incisiones cortes a través de la piel
en su lugar una máquina se enfoca y
envía con precisión alrededor de 200
ases de radiación a un área objetivo
dentro de la cabeza
la radiación solo mata a las células
anormales sin afectar el tejido normal
que se encuentra alrededor de ellas
gamma knife se utiliza para tratar
tumores cerebrales pequeños
malformaciones en los vasos sanguíneos y
afecciones nerviosas que son difíciles
de alcanzar o demasiado riesgosas para
tratar con otros métodos
el armazón craneal de gamma knife tiene
cuatro clavos o tornillos
después de adormecer el cuero cabelludo
el médico adhiere el armazón craneal con
los tornillos el armazón evita el
movimiento de la cabeza y ayuda a guiar
los haces de radiación con el armazón
craneal en su lugar se realiza un
estudio por imágenes como rm etc para
determinar el tamaño la forma y la
ubicación exactos del objetivo que debe
tratarse el equipo de tratamiento
utiliza los estudios por imágenes y un
software avanzado para crear un plan de
tratamiento
y luego el paciente se acuesta en la
camilla de gamma knife se coloca un
casco de radiación sobre el armazón
craneal el casco contiene agujeros que
sólo permiten el paso de la radiación
programada del plan de tratamiento
con el casco en su lugar se desliza la
camilla hacia la unidad de radiación
este procedimiento es silencioso e
indoloro demora entre unos minutos y una
hora o más según el tamaño y la forma
del área de tratamiento
los efectos sobre el tumor ocurren
durante un periodo de tiempo después del
procedimiento
para obtener más información consulte a
su médico